now we're marking Remembrance Sunday in
many ways this weekend but how about
having a chance to hear some wartime
tunes listening to the retro sounds of
the d-day darlings is the perfect way to
do it
they made it big on Britain's Got Talent
this year of course their mission is to
remember the sacrifices made by those
who went to war for their country yes
with us now what a treat our singers
Katie Ashby Jessica Hudson and Amy
Rhiannon of the d-day darlings thank you
so much for coming in thanks for having
us firstly why do you do what you do we
love it we love honoring heroes we love
keeping the memories alive for all those
that sacrifice so much obviously during
World War one and World War two blast so
current military as well so we just want
to touch all those lives that have
sacrificed so much for all of us Amy how
did it start
the d-day darlings well I believe Katie
was singing in old people's homes
singing songs that people wanted to hear
and that connection with those people
from that generation that they loved the
songs that we sing they enjoyed it so
much they join in with all the words
because you know they've sung those
songs all their lives so it's just a
real privilege to sing for them and it's
it's grown from there you know to from
years of service yeah yeah it's been
wonderful just to take those veterans
back in those older generation that
lived through those times to see on
their faces it's yeah do you also sort
of try and connect with the younger
generations as well is that part of what
you're aiming to do yeah it's really
important that he's put into the younger
generation the hardship the sacrifice
that was made because I'm growing up
myself I had such an interest in the
both wars and I think now it's so
important especially as the generations
are going I mean 100 years since the end
of World War one it's just important
that we keep the history and the message
in to the younger generation Casey is it
can it be quite tough you know if you a
lot of your time must be spent
obviously singing to the older
generation who must obviously speak to
you about their experiences their
memories friends they've lost it can be
tough it's it's a wonderful thing to be
able to do to bring back those memories
but they are hard memories for them too
but we can't forget them so I think that
just shows the strength of the people
that still want to relive those memories
because they can't forget them so it's
just an honor to listen to
stories into here what they went through
but it is hard as a generation from what
we come from to try and fully understand
what they went through we never probably
will presumably you can see visibly than
them connecting with your performance
must be don't take their eyes off us now
they don't take their eyes off us and
you can see tears in their eyes you can
see stories in their faces where they
were when they we have an air-raid siren
that played at the start of the show
that is haunting and you can see
everyone has a different experience of
that and it's really moving yeah music
is so emotive as well and it's so
important I mean we've had situations
where people that have lost their memory
I think every single word to our music
and their family are in tears because
they think we haven't had a conversation
with them for something every single
word this music is so important but it's
also morale-building the songs were
designed for that time to see them
through those tough times those dark
days they were specifically written for
that so it is morale building it's not
all tears there is you know tears of joy
and they wave the flags and sing along
is a name we speaking of speaking of the
songs in the repertoire it's mainly
World War 2 era music that you guys
perform isn't it and whether that do you
see a time when obviously the people who
are owned at that time and will remember
all the worse those songs are fading
away yes and obviously that will happen
I mean will be one of the last
generations really to have that direct
contact with our own grandparents you
know to speak to them directly and
obviously that's going to change over
time which is one of the reasons why
we're trying to keep the memories alive
and pass it on to you and you feel a
responsibility I suppose as a younger
generation to do that one of our aims
yeah we feel like we're the the perfect
generation to do it because we start we
still close to connect with our
grandparents and there is still people
around to tell us those stories and we
just need to pass that message on and we
are passing the message on we know since
Britain's Got Talent we've got children
huge fans you know they've come to
events they're waving the flags the
little you want to know they've shown
come in that we're on Britain's Got
Talent with you it's part of a wider
and for Britain's Got Talent to put it
on it was just ladies we could continue
to talk actually hear you sing so thank
you for doing so over to you
they'll be
bluebirds over the White Cliffs of Dover
tomorrow just you wait and see
they'll be love and laughter and peace
never after tomorrow when the world is
free the Shepherd will tend his she
[Music]
my yeah
and cheer me we'll go to sleep
here's all little room
again they'll be
[Music]
over
the White Cliffs of Dover tomorrow just
you wait
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Wow absolutely amazing I've got goose
ballet DS thank you so so much that was
fantastic we really appreciate you
coming
thanks guys